all right we've been telling you for
over a year that former FBI director
James Comey and his decision not to
recommend charges against Hillary
Clinton over the email server was based
solely on politics not on evidence on
now there appears to be the proof we've
been looking for
according to senators chuck Grassley and
Lindsey Graham well the FBI director was
drafting a letter that exonerated
Hillary Clinton months before the bureau
even interviewed the former Secretary of
State and many key witnesses
this is beyond disgusting embarrassing
and beyond shameful it's exactly why we
have been telling you that there is a
two-tiered justice system sadly in
America today one for the Clintons and
one for the rest of us tonight you the
American people you should be outraged
because it looks like the fix was in
from the get-go so enough is enough the
country deserves to know what the truth
is about exactly what James Comey was
trying to do here and it's time for the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he must
now reopen Hillary Clinton's email
server case and investigate James comas
role in letting her go free without a
real investigation also Congress they
must investigate all of this and they've
got to get to the truth they have
subpoena and they have investigative
powers now it's time for them to use it
now remember before unilaterally
announcing that the FBI wasn't
recommending prosecuting Hillary Clinton
James Comey laid out in painstaking
detail how Clinton had secret top-secret
classified and special access program
information on that email server and we
also found out later that of course up
to five foreign intelligence agencies
likely gained access to that server
those are crimes
now here's Comey being questioned by
congressman trey Gowdy and detailing all
the times that Hillary lied during the
server scandal pay attention
Secretary Clinton said there was nothing
marked classified on her emails either
sent or received was that true that's
not true there were a small number of
portion markings on I think three of the
documents Secretary Clinton said I did
not email any classified material to
anyone on my email there is no
classified material was
true there was classified material
emailed Secretary Clinton said all
work-related emails were returned to the
State Department was that true no we
found work-related emails thousands that
were not returned that's the FBI
director admitting the Clinton lied
pretty much every step of the way but
somehow without interviewing Clinton or
other key witnesses he was able to
conclude that Clinton didn't break the
law now it doesn't make any sense and it
reeks of corruption and collusion this
also proves the President Trump was
absolutely right to fire James Comey as
the FBI director this guy is clearly
amoral he doesn't care about the rule of
law and he only acted in his ownself
best interest and of course with an
agenda this exoneration letter is just
the beginning of what are very highly
questionable unethical and potentially
criminal behavior from the former FBI
director James Comey for starters it
looks like call me perjured himself in
front of Congress by saying that he made
his decision about Clinton after talking
to her sorry
time line doesn't fit take a look at
this director did you make the decision
not to recommend criminal charges
relating to classified information
before or after Hillary Clinton was
interviewed by the FBI on July the
second after but if colleagues of ours
believe I am lying about when I made
this decision please urge them to
contact me privately so we can have a
conversation about this all I can do is
tell you again the decision was made
after that because I didn't know what
was going to happen in that interview
she maybe lied during the interview in a
way we could prove so now it looks like
James called me lied to Congress but his
behavior is not surprising giving
everything else that we have learned
about the former FBI director it appears
he's a rogue agent he doesn't care about
enforcing the law otherwise this never
would have happened
and remember Comey may have broken the
law by drafting memos on the government
computer after he met with Donald Trump
and then removing those documents from
the FBI and then of course he also
admitted before Congress that he had his
best friend leaked the contents of the
memos to the New York Times in the hopes
that it would bring about a special
Council which in fact it did and we
can't forget about Comey testifying the
former
terney general Loretta Lynch had
pressured him into calling the Clinton
investigation a matter in public and he
ended up listening and doing that so the
former FBI director is also a massive
hypocrite he claims to have detailed
notes and memos about private
conversations that he had with President
Trump but he didn't write a single word
down about his conversations with
Loretta Lynch here's what's important if
this country still cares about
respecting the Constitution the rule of
law equal application of the law then
it's time to reopen the Clinton server
case and investigate everything that
called me prematurely exonerated Hillary
Clinton for and call me himself he needs
to be held accountable for these actions
but they are inexcusable and that's a
very important aspect to a
constitutional republic
now also tonight President Trump is
overturning one of President Obama's
massive abuses of power here's what the
president said earlier today let's take
a look I have a great heart for these
folks we're talking about a great love
for them and people think in terms of
children but they're really young adults
I have a love for these people and
hopefully now Congress will be able to
help them and do it properly and I can
tell you and speaking to members of
Congress they want to be able to do
something and do it right and really we
have no choice we have to be able to do
something and I think it's going to work
out very well and long-term it's going
to be the right solution
now the left to destroy Trump
establishment media predictably there in
freakout mode about the president's
decision but then again they freaked out
over Melania shoes but this is because
they obviously don't care about the
Constitution the rule of law what they
won't tell you is that Daka was in fact
unconstitutional that the president is
right to let Congress decide on the
issue of immigration laws in this
country
that's our system of checks and balances
is supposed to work the executive branch
can't assert power from the legislative
branch and you may remember how
President Obama himself admitted this
many many times before ever signing this
executive order on daca he admitted it
was unconstitutional
for him to change immigration laws all
on his own so let's listen to the
constitutional scholar former President
Obama sometimes when I talk to
immigration advocates you know they wish
I could just bypass Congress and change
the law myself but that's not how
democracy works the notion that I can
just suspend deportations through
executive order that's just not the case
now I know some people want me to bypass
Congress and change the laws on my own
but that's not how that's not how our
system works that's that's that's not
how our democracy functions that's not
how our Constitution is written not how
our Constitution is written not how
democracy works now after saying even
all of that Obama did it anyway which is
why President Trump is a thousand
percent right did the right thing this
morning isn't going to trample over the
rule of law in the Constitution well now
the ball is rightly in Congress's court
they want to change the law they can go
right ahead and they'll be held
accountable that's their job so now it's
put up or shut up time and that means
Mitch McConnell all his friends in the
Senate all the people in the house
because this is exactly what they wanted
watch this if the president follows
through on his threat for executive
amnesty what do you have in terms of
tools at your disposal to stop him from
doing that well first of all it's
unconstitutional so we're already going
through the court system on other
unconstitutional executive orders that
he is he has worked on and we would add
this to the pile the action he's
proposed would ignore the law would
reject the voice of the voters and would
impose new unfairness on law-abiding
immigrants all without solving the
problem in fact his action is more
likely to make it even worse all right
now in addition to acting on daca and
immigration and by the way funding the
wall Congress has a litany of other
problems to tackle like keeping the
government funded be on the 30th of
September raising the debt ceiling
approving hurricane Harvie aid repealing
and replacing Obamacare
before the Budget Reconciliation option
runs out at the end of the month
funding president Trump's border wall
very important moving ahead on tax
reform and tax cuts that's important so
for all you members in Congress you
better get your act together you have 14
weeks to actually start passing the
things that you promised and the
President's agenda the things the
American people voted for 14 weeks to
keep your promises do your job
by the way Mitch McConnell mister 18%
approval rating in your state are you
watching better take down notes pay
attention because the American people
are watching these are simple things all
right let's take the tax code from seven
brackets to three let's cut middle-class
taxes let's slash the corporate tax rate
to fifteen percent so that they'll build
factories and manufacturing centers in
in this country allow multinational
corporations and companies to repatriate
trillions parked overseas so they can
hire the new workers and invest right
here in the United States and also
building at least I would argue 300
miles of the wall and fund the entire
wall and you better do it before the
2018 midterm elections or the American
people might just say goodbye to you
energy independence so important the
lifeblood of our economy and yes start
working on a repeal and replacement of
Obamacare because so many Americans are
suffering so in other words it's time
for Congress to come together and get
your job done for once with a sense of
urgency and finally tonight we have a
very scary situation out of North Korea
that puts the entire world in jeopardy
tonight over the weekend the rogue
regime conducted yet its sixth nuclear
test of a hydrogen bomb that they claim
can fit on the end of a long-range
missile that we've been seeing they've
been test firing now pyongyang is also
once again threatening america by saying
they will send quote gift packages to
the US and according to South Korea's
military Kim jong-un he appears to be
preparing for another ICBM test now this
comes after the rogue regime flew a
missile right over Japan just last week
now meanwhile the president his
administration general mattis they
continue to turn up the heat on North
Korea and the president announcing
earlier today that Japan and South Korea
will
able to buy a quote substantially
increased amount of sophisticated US
military equipment and the president
also tweeted quote the United States is
considering in addition to other options
stopping all trade with any country
doing business with North Korea and last
week prior to the hydrogen bomb test the
u.s. and South Korea carried out a
massive show of force by conducting a
simulated live-fire bombing raid now
unfortunately there are no good
solutions as I've been saying to dealing
with North Korea and this threat if the
United States and our allies carry out a
preemptive strike knocking out Kim
jong-un's nuclear sites well we don't
know what that will lead to a potential
all-out war in the Korean Peninsula
literally putting millions of lives at
risk
so what's clear is we cannot repeat the
mistakes of the past like this policy of
appeasement that was carried out under
Bill Clinton remember it was Bill
Clinton it was back in the 1990's I'll
quote the New York Times to make all
liberals happy he cut a deal with Kim
jong-un's father Kim jong-il where the
u.s. agreed to give North Korea billions
of dollars in energy aid over the course
of a decade all in exchange for
Pyongyang promising they're going to be
good little government officials and
despots and they'll end their nuclear
program according to the framework of
that agreement North Korea would allow
inspectors to the nuclear sites but it
came with a very big catch they would
also be allowed to keep their nuclear
fuel rods which can be used obviously to
make weapons for an unspecified number
of years of course Bill Clinton he
brushed all those fears aside tried to
bribe them into being nice and even
praised this ridiculous deal that
brought us to where we are today to the
brink what's this this is a good deal
for the United States North Korea will
freeze and then dismantle its nuclear
program South Korea and our other allies
will be better protected the entire
world will be safer as we slow the
spread of nuclear weapons the United
States and international inspectors will
carefully monitor North Korea to make
sure it keeps its commitments only as it
does so will North Korea fully join the
community of
nation's alright so as we all later
found out Bill Clinton he got played he
turned out to be completely wrong and
now the world is in great jeopardy and
by 1998 North Korea they test fired a
long-range missile in 2006 the rogue
regime conducted their first nuclear
test and then under the Obama
administration the North Korean threat
accelerated while the former president
drastically cut our strategic defense
capabilities this is now left President
Trump
facing a giant crisis with no good
answers because as we learn from Neville
Chamberlain the policies of appeasement
in capitulation it never works when
you're dealing with despots and
dictators now President Clinton and
Obama has kicked the can down the road
leaving it for someone else to deal with
and now here we are we just can't you
know wait for North Korea to fully
develop a nuclear arsenal that can hit
major American cities
so we now must accelerate president
Trump's plan and seriously bolster the
Fed and other anti-missile defense
systems we also need to fast-track the
technology from President Reagan's
Strategic Defense Initiative
so that unlike conventional missile
defense systems we have 30 40 shots to
shoot down any ICBM that North Korea is
ending up firing and in other words we
need a lot of options and a lot of
opportunities or o'the millions could
die in my opinion the US needs to take
out any North Korean missile that is
launched or if they put it on a pad and
we don't know what's on that missile
well we need to take that out as well
this is beyond serious we need to let
Kim jong-un know that those types of
aggressive actions will never be
tolerated